[Applause]
[Music]
20:20 has been hijacked by the corona
virus pandemic
[Music]
however beyond this crisis there are
other world events that are worth
mentioning which we have to tell you
about bands in particular this one
during the early months of 2020 the
United States ended the longest war in
its history yes I think almost all of us
can remember when and how the war in
Afghanistan began good evening today our
fellow citizens our way of life our very
freedom came under attack in a series of
deliberate and deadly terrorist acts
what I'm sure few expected was an ending
like this after 19 years a sad epilogue
has been reached for two military
operations that received such bombastic
names as Enduring Freedom and sentry of
Liberty it's the end of a whole
deployment of resources suffering and
money so that in the end freedom in
Afghanistan has had little or no lasting
effects and that well being a century
has only been kind of a joke within the
framework of America's first new
strategy America first America first
so the question is what does this deal
between the Trump administration the
Taliban really mean what role will this
affair play in the u.s. presidential
election and most importantly for
Afghanistan how long will peace last
[Music]
today on visual politic we know armed
cell all these questions but before we
do let's take a look back at some
history a silent toofie Afghanistan
celebrated the centenary of its
independence from the United Kingdom in
2019 100 years of independence as a
country although in this case we could
say that it's all just a bit of hot air
Afghans have been at war for more than
40 years moving from one conflict to
another and then to another and another
and all these conflicts obviously have
consequences Afghanistan is now Asia's
poorest country and its level of
development has gone backwards to 1950
levels to give you an idea Afghanistan's
modern problems began in 1979 when the
Soviet Union invaded the country to
support the communist regime that emerge
from the Saar evolution it was the Cold
War era in the United States's reaction
didn't take long in arriving Jimmy
Carter first and Ronald Reagan later
supported the Mujahideen in their fight
against the Soviets
since then the country would say goodbye
to any stable and lasting peace around
the same time the CIA saw some bearded
boys chiefly firing their rifles into
the app and then someone in Langley must
have thought it was a good idea to fund
those Islamic rebels the rest of the
story is well known the Soviets withdrew
defeated and the United States avoided a
communist regime but peace did not
settle in Afghanistan
the in fighting continued among the
warlords and eventually Afghanistan
ended up in the hands of the Taliban an
Islamist group that took over much of
the country in the 1990s which surprise
surprise is still there look at this
news from just a year ago US military
stops counting how much of Afghanistan
is controlled by Taliban we know that
they established Islamic lorentz they
had many ideas and unfortunately they
were all really really terrible for
example they banned women from public
life and locked them in their burkas and
in their homes they dynamited the
Buddha's of Bamiyan symbols of Afghan
heritage and welcomed Islamic terrorists
like Osama bin Laden
so barely a month before the 9/11 attack
George Bush ordered the start of
Operation Enduring Freedom in 2001 our
response involves far more than instant
retaliation and isolated strikes
Americans should not expect one battle
but a lengthy campaign unlike any other
we have ever seen bombings of Taliban
and al-qaeda forces began and soon after
there was an invasion as you can imagine
nineteen years of war in Afghanistan is
more than enough but throughout all of
these years 2011 was a turning point
good evening tonight I can report to the
American people and to the world the
United States has conducted an operation
that killed Osama bin Laden the leader
of al-qaeda when the United States took
down a sama bin Laden on May the 2nd
2011 it was as if the drama that had
started on 9/11 had suddenly ended from
that day on having a US presence in
Afghanistan became increasingly
uncomfortable and a justification
increasingly difficult to understand
that's why the Obama administration drew
up an exit plan NATO in the United
States reduced troops on the ground in
2015 operation century of freedom had
begun the goal was no longer to fight
the Taliban but to simply train forces
loyal to the governments and for the
Afghans themselves to ensure the
security of the country
what happened then well we covered this
in a different visual politic video as
NATO withdrew its forces the Taliban
regained ground since then however the
widespread feeling in the West is that
the worst of the war has already passed
something like okay I'm not exactly
booking my next holiday to Kabul but
well things in Afghanistan have come a
long way since 2010 when NATO suffered
more than 700 casualties and yes it's
true in the five years that operation
freedoms Sentinel has lasted only 110
coalition soldiers fell in action only
but this does not mean that tranquility
has returned to Afghan soil far from its
violence in Afghanistan last year was
worse than in Syria today the Taliban
are active in 70% of the country and
almost completely dominate rural areas
so yes while hardly any more Americans
are dying in a way things for
Afghanistan ease even worse the 19 years
of Western presence in Afghanistan have
served neither to defeat the Taliban nor
to create strong democratic institutions
to get the country back on track today
the Afghan government has no authority
in the face of tribal hierarchies the
situation is so complicated that
elections were held in September and the
results were not known until February
five months later to top it all off both
President Ashraf Ghani and opposition
leader Abdullah Abdullah have claimed
victory thus in the absence of one
strong government Afghanistan currently
has two equally inoperative governments
but let's just tell it like it is none
of this matters to anyone absolutely no
one
negotiations on the future of
Afghanistan have been conducted by the
United States in the Taliban without
regard to the government of Kabul okay
so now you might be wondering well what
does Donald Trump think of Afghanistan
I don't want to kill ten million people
I have plans on Afghanistan that if I
wanted to win that war Afghanistan would
be wiped off the face of the earth it
would be gun it would be over in
literally in ten days and I don't want
to do that I don't want to go that route
you see the thing is before he was
president Trump always said that he'd
get the troops out of Afghanistan that
the Americans had no reason to be in
those lands but as we've discussed on
this channel before when he arrived at
the White House he continued Obama's
strategy with one fundamental change he
avoided a withdrawal date
and the truth is this was a successful
ploy but why well think about it for a
moment what happens when parents tell
their teenage children they won't be
home for a weekend well the kids have a
party at the house and the longer you
give them to organise it the more
friends will come to the party bus here
Trump who has five children said no
you're not gonna get me into this in
Afghanistan we will act according to the
circumstances given these circumstances
the game with the Taliban is not very
different and not having a fixed
withdrawal date is the best card you can
play in fact the short-term set of
withdrawal dates was probably one of the
biggest mistakes for a cabana made the
fact is that the Taliban who already
started playing for night while waiting
for the Wester to pack up realized that
with Trump they had to change their
plans but no matter how much their
troops advanced on the grounds this war
against the United States would never be
won on the battlefield now having all
the wild cards in hand why not go to the
bargaining table well no sooner said
than done that's exactly what happens
the Taliban at Camp David
when Trump invited the Taliban to the
presidential residence of Camp David in
September 2019 to sign a peace
agreements his plan was to bang on the
table to bang on about his image of
course the image of the Taliban in Camp
David the same place where Egypt in
Israel ended 30 years of conflicts all
looked very impressive one year after
the election Trump would be forever the
president who ended the Afghanistan war
unfortunately for the Afghan people
however the terms of the agreement made
between the United States and the
Taliban lead us to think that all this
staging has more to do with scripting
and image than with the Taliban's evils
suddenly becoming good proof of this is
how complicated the negotiations of then
take a look
Donald Trump delegated the peace
negotiations that took place in Doha
between the United States and the
Taliban to Afghan American diplomat
salmiak al-assad the Afghan governments
which has been largely ignored
throughout the process was the one who
was not present in the Qatari capital
calles odds have already closed the deal
the previous September in this way
everything was prearranged to such an
extent that Trump invited the Taliban to
Camp David to rubric eyes the agreements
on the eve of the 9/11 anniversary yep
that's right the Taliban at Camp David
on 9/11 in Trump's head it sounded
spectacular but hold on a moment because
just a few days before the events this
happens
Trump declares us Taliban talks dead
after canceling Camp David meeting so
why did Trump cancel the encounter with
the Taliban when everything was ready
was there anything in the agreements
that didn't convince him
well the truth is no the thing is there
was a Taliban attack in Kabul and 12
people were killed so just a usual day
in the Afghan capital but this time a US
soldier died and in the White House
someone came up with the thought of
saying we're really gonna sign a peace
treaty with some guys who are unable to
maintain a truce while we negotiate so
the deal came close to falling apart
of course the fact that a politician
like Trump gave up on the talks in
September means the two months later
they were negotiating again
and what had changed in that time well
no absolutely nothing
the only thing from house in his sight
line is the coming November election and
being the presidents who finished the
Afghan conflict where more than two
thousand US soldiers have been killed
further more than twenty thousand have
been injured in a trillion dollars has
been spent more or less the GDP of a
country such as Spain
and let's be clear at this point what
matters least to Trump is the future of
Afghanistan
but what exactly does the agreement say
while the peace agreement states that
the United States will withdraw all of
its forces from Afghanistan within 14
months in return the Taliban agrees not
to host international terrorist
organizations such as al-qaeda and - the
Taliban are also being tasked with
negotiating Afghanistan's political
future with the Afghan government's
conversations that are to be accompanied
by exchanges of prisoners and hostages
on both sides and yes I know you're
thinking the conditions of a Taliban
victory seem more like the conditions of
the u.s. victory but at this point
that's no longer the most important
thing the key to all of this is whether
the Taliban can really be trusted and
the Trump administration itself is clear
not really
so do you want to know what the United
States asked of the Taliban as a
demonstration of goodwill well listen up
[Music]
the friend of the mullah after 9/11 and
nineteen years of war the US government
called on the Taliban to proved that
they could sit still for a week
yes it's as if they were at some kind of
terrorists Anonymous group hi I'm a talk
about member Ivan planted bomb in five
days now
hang in there kids we're on your size
the surprising truth is that according
to the Afghan government during those
days violence fell by 80% enough for the
United States which this time did sign
the agreement with the Taliban
of course that was very the 29th and you
know what happened three days later well
no more no less than this Taliban
resumes attacks on Afghan forces five
policemen died in fact the Taliban have
signed the agreement with the United
States but continued to attack Afghan
forces nor is it much of a surprise
because it is what they have done all
throughout the peace negotiations and so
what does Trump say to this well on this
matter the president is in 100%
electoral mode always letting out such
stirring phrases as the time has come to
bring our people home while the Taliban
were attacking the Afghans the president
of the United States said things like
this we've been there for 20 years other
presidents of try today have been unable
to get any kind of an agreement the
relationship is very good that I have
with the mullah and we had a good long
conversation today and you know they
want to cease the violence they'd like
to see smile and sauce
while we are about to witness a peace
agreements that basically amounts to
nothing but a withdrawal regardless of
the consequences of course it is not
clear in the case of Afghanistan that
there is any alternative either but the
question is will this agreements with
the Taliban served Trump's propaganda
and surely it will Democrats tried with
the Bama to win the war by putting a
hundred thousand men on the grounds and
failed as a result Biden cannot brag too
much about Afghanistan and also says he
was always in favor of reducing troops
there it is also true that abandoning
Afghanistan to its own devices does not
seem to matter much to Americans in the
era of coronavirus but by now you might
be wondering well Simon what does the
Afghan government have to say about all
of this after all the Taliban are
continuing their game plan attacks on
Afghan security forces car bombs more
attacks more over things have become so
difficult that if a Taliban has a bullet
left in the Kalashnikov he shoots an
Afghan policeman over an American
soldier in fact the police have already
withdrawn negotiations between the
Afghan government and the Taliban were
supposed to have begun on March the 10th
in Oslo however everything is running
behind President Ashraf Ghani and his
opponent Abdullah Abdullah are still
vying for power in addition the Taliban
attacks continue and if this were not
enough there is one more obstacle that
will slow the march of progress the
coronavirus has also now arrived in
Afghanistan well at least the latest
news indicates progress in the exchange
of prisoners and hostages as a starting
point to negotiations Afghanistan
prepares to swap 100 Taliban prisoners
for 20 security forces what is the
support of US troops who should no
longer be there within a year as agreed
by Trump the other is that the Taliban
want freedom for the thousands of their
men that NATO the United States and
government forces have put in Afghan
prisons and of course under the
agreement signed by Trump the government
must release 5,000 Taliban before
political negotiations on Afghanistan's
future the real ones
begin so you can more or less get a
sense of who's winning but now it's your
turn
do you agree with Trump's formula for
finishing the Afghanistan war leave your
answer in the comments section below and
I really do hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also please do check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and support
our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video and if you
want to learn more about politics and
here even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]